wonderful um so I'm de San Davis I'm a
PhD scientist and I'm the program
manager here at Rock edu and the mission
of Rakhi to you is to offer many
opportunities for all of you your
friends your teachers and your neighbors
to engage with science is a relevant
human endeavor and for you to explore
ways that science is relevant to your
lives and we're really excited about the
talk today because we think that this is
one is that's really relevant to our
lives in our communities and learning
how to talk about addiction as a
scientist and using the data that we
know about addiction to inform how we
think about an approach addiction as a
society we think is super super
important so we're really really looking
forward to this talk today so our talk
is going to be presented by Devin
Collins Devin is a graduate student here
at Rockefeller being a graduate student
means that Devin already graduated from
undergrad he graduated from Ball State
University after growing up in Chicago
it means that he's now pursuing his PhD
so he's been at that for about yeah go
ahead applaud that that's great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so he's five years into that endeavor
and finishing up his PhD which is really
him dedicating a whole lot of time a
little bit as you think of as a student
learning things in traditional ways but
mostly learning things through his own
discoveries in his own research and his
work at the bench and he's going to
share some of what he knows and some of
his work with us today between
graduating from undergraduate and
joining Rockefeller Devin worked as both
a research assistant I have to get
correct which is which research
assistant at Indiana State School of
Medicine and as a research technician at
the University of Chicago and then we
were lucky enough to get him to New York
here and so specifically here at
Rockefeller Devin is working in the lab
of dr. Mary Jean Creek she's one of the
very first women scientists women heads
of lab here at the Rockefeller
University she's an amazing woman with
an amazing story and she and her lab
have made remarkable contributions to
our current understanding of addiction
as disease and specifically of addiction
as a treatable disease and Devin's going
to be telling us a lot about that today
because that's an important part of
addiction research today outside of the
lab Devin does a lot of stuff for us
with Rakhi to you including that he's
been the instructor or one of the
instructors for our learning at the
bench program formerly known as the
after-school program now known as the
jumpstart program I'm gonna plug it for
a second because nominations just opened
so if you guys are interested in a
research opportunity where you get to go
from like passion and the cool
interesting things that make you guys
want to come sit in these chairs to
learning the actual skills and
techniques that you need in order to
spend a whole summer doing research with
us this is the lab jump start program it
starts after school in the spring and
continues as a full-time summer research
experience there's a stipend there's
metro cards there's food we take really
good care of you guys you get to hang
out with really cool people probably not
Devon this year because he's graduating
and moving on but other cool people like
Devon um and it's a really great
opportunity if you're interested in
exploring what it means to actually do
science research so if you're interested
you need to have a teacher nominate you
the nominations are open and as soon as
that teacher completes the nomination
you get to start working on your
application you can check it out on our
website
w wrff led you slash outreach that's
also a great place to sign up for our
newsletter though if you signed up
through Eventbrite you'll be
automatically added to our newsletter to
know about future events like this and
other
cool things that were running alright
alright I've said a lot we're gonna let
Devin take over and tell you his great
story about his work with addiction
research all right let me get plugged in
here real quick it's anybody what Steven
universe yeah who's your favorite Jim
garnet Yeah right
all right we got some technical
difficulties here for a sec ah cool all
right we got it all right so like this
and said I'm a graduate student here at
the Rockefeller University and I work
for a woman named Mary teen Creek and in
the Creek lab were really interested in
studying addiction in lots of different
ways so some of the things we do are
explore some of the neurobiological
mechanisms that go into making people
addicted and we also think about some of
the other biological factors like
genetics that can predispose some people
to addiction and maybe even protect
others from from developing addiction in
the first place and so I want to talk
about you what I want to talk about with
you today is some of what scientists
have been able to learn about how
addiction takes place and some of the
changes that drugs can wreak on the
brain but first I want to think about
this in like a historical and global
perspective right so we all know that
addiction is a really big deal right I'm
sure that like you all agree people have
used mind-altering substances for
thousands and thousands of years and
unfortunately for some of us repeated
use of some of those substances and for
some people that can lead to the disease
of addiction and when people and that
means that people have thought a lot
about it right so addiction is a big
deal it has tremendous personal
interpersonal economic and societal
costs and so that means that people
really want to figure out why addiction
happens and also what to do about it
right and so unfortunately because we
didn't always have science to figure out
what was going on with this disease
there's been a lot of historical
misconceptions about what causes it and
what I want to talk about is what
scientists have been able to learn and
and just to dispel some of those myths
and like really bad stereotypes about
personal willpower and like lack of
morality and stuff finish which is just
not true right all right so
drug use in addiction so let's think
about what kinds of drugs people
actually use there are lots of different
kinds right there things like alcohol
there's methamphetamine marijuana
prescription pills you guys watch house
all right what about narcos cocaine and
who recognizes this what's it from yeah
okay cool I thought that you might be
too young for that reference but that's
great all right so those are some of the
things that people do use right how many
people have used and I want you to keep
in mind that the numbers I'm about to
show you are from a survey of Americans
aged 12 or older all right so keep that
in mind all right
260 million people in the u.s. 12 or
older have ever used drugs so again keep
that in mind ever use them in their life
right 15 are sorry it's not drugs
alcohol 15 million have used
methamphetamine 104 million have ever
used marijuana about 37 million have
ever used prescription pills for cocaine
it's about 46 million and about 5.7
million have ever used heroin so that's
how many people in the US over age 12
have ever used those drugs right but not
all of those people are going to go on
to develop addiction right so how many
people go on to develop dependency or
addiction for alcohol is about 16
million people and these numbers are
actually I don't know why both of those
went up whatever and these numbers are
actually people in the Pat in the year
2015 from some national survey data
these are people who qualified for
chemical dependency right so in 2015
about 16 million people met the criteria
for alcohol dependency or addiction
about 870 2004 methamphetamine about 4
million for for marijuana prescription
pills that's about 6 million and this
number is actually really interesting
because this even though prescription
pills are like a really broad category
so they think
they include things like barbiturates
and tranquilizers and stimulants this
number really represents a huge number
of people who are using prescription
opioids so things like painkillers like
Vicodin Oxycontin and percocet about
eight hundred ninety six thousand met
the criteria for cocaine dependence and
about 591 thousand people were dependent
or addicted dependent on are addicted to
heroin and I want to zero in on this
number just a little bit closer and kind
of dissect something about it when
people regularly expose themselves to
heroin which is an opioid drug about
twenty to thirty three percent of people
go on to develop an addiction when they
regularly expose themselves to that drug
and Ikeys us into something that's
actually a really huge percentage
because if you look at something like
alcohol or cocaine there's a big
percentage of those people who get
addicted to those drugs but it's only
about six to twelve compared to this
much bigger number here and that Clues
us in about something that might be
special about opioids and so I'm gonna
go a little bit further into that drug
because it's actually what I study in
the lab so before we do that let's think
about some of the factors that go into
creating an addiction and my slide is
kind of like jump the gun here but I
like to think about three different
areas that can kind of encompass the
different factors that go into making an
addiction so things like biology and
examples of those are things like
genetics physiology which is the way
that the systems in your body function
cognition which is how your brain kind
of takes in processes and deals with
information and the neuro chemistry
which is how the cells in your brain
talk to one another in the environment
there are factors like stressors social
pressure drug exposure and this is super
key because addiction is a disease that
requires something from the outside
changing biology right so you're not
going to have an addiction if you don't
have drug exposures so this is a really
important environmental factor right and
it should it's kind of a no-brainer
they're also drug cues which signal
availability of drugs in the environment
so if you are a person who has an
addiction and you see like something
that can sing
availability of your drug of choice in
the environment then that's gonna cue
you in and maybe might cost crazy
craving or something like that and then
there are pharmacological aspects to
addiction right so once a drug is on
board and in your body where is it
working what's the target
when it's at its target what's the
mechanism by which it exerts its effects
and once those effects I've started how
long do they last and so we're going to
zero in in today's talk on some of the
biological factors including physiology
cognition in neuro chemistry and we're
also going to look at some of the
pharmacological factors like drug target
and it's going to lead us to one of my
favorite proteins ever it's really great
all right but before we do that I want
to make sure that we're kind of all on
the same page and come up with a
framework that we're gonna think about
today's talking right so I want you to
keep some things in mind all right so
we've got a brain right and that's
really important for lots of things I
think the brain is a really cool part of
the body because it does so much for us
right it regulates our heartbeat
it helps coordinate things like
digestion it communicates with all of
these different organs and and helps to
coordinate their activities and like you
can help you live right but the brain
also does a lot of other things for us
that I'm gonna get into it and in just a
few slides right so I've kind of already
given you the answer but what do all of
these things have in common what are
they organs exactly right and so what
happens when actually let's come on
alright there we go alright so you've
already got kind of a reveal there but
so let's let's look more closely at two
of these organs right when you have
heart disease what are some of the
consequences of that anybody yeah
myocardial infarction right that wasn't
great that's a nice piece of vocabulary
that's good all right what else what
does the heart do let's think about it
and that in that regard
what does art do for you it pumps blood
right so if you have a myocardial
infarction or heart disease right that
means that the heart can't pump can't
pump blood as well
right all right so what do you have an
organ that's responsible for behavior
what do you think the behaviors might be
changed right because the brain is an
organ that is responsible for generating
behaviors and so addiction involves
behaviors in that it's a disease of the
brain right and so when you think about
what the beat what the brain does for us
you can think a lot about how addiction
might might change how our what our
behaviors are right and that's
illustrated really well here oh man that
was a bad voice crack it's illustrated
right here in this chart or in this this
cartoon in that this disease tart on the
right here is functioning differently
than a healthy heart and likewise a
diseased brain is functioning
differently from a healthy brain right
I'm kind of batting you over the head
with these things but I want to make
sure that we keep these in mind all
right and what's really cool about this
specific example is that this disease
that this brain is suffering from is a
specific disease of cocaine addiction
all right so we've established that the
brain is an organ and the brain can get
sick right we also know that the brain
helps us to understand and adapt to our
surroundings so like I was saying the
brain helps us generate behaviors and
some of those behaviors needs to be
adaptive and I'm gonna illustrate that
to you right now right all right so if
you're thirsty this image probably looks
really good to you right now right so
imagine that you're like us like an
animal that's super thirsty out on the
Savannah you haven't had water for days
and then you see some signs of water in
the environment right what are you gonna
do you're going to follow those signs
and you're going to try to find water
right because your body needs it it's
really important for survival and so you
find some water you drink it you get
your fill and then you're done right you
can stop drinking so you don't just like
drink water forever and ever and ever
just because you were thirsty once right
so your brain can adapt it did to behave
it helped you to generate the behaviors
necessary to find and get the water and
then it stopped those behaviors right
and it turns out that there are brain
systems that are in place for both of
those
things and this is really important
because you can put a brake on the
system so like this baby does not want
that food you can say no to certain
things that are otherwise good other
than other contexts all right so we know
that learning and adapting behavior is
essential to life and that the brain
does this for us and learning adapting
is really important because we want to
make more of these right we have to
survive and grow and reproduce I love
blue all right so keeping those things
in mind let's talk a little bit about
the brain and then we can get into what
drugs do to it dang I hope that Blue Ivy
and Beyonce don't like upstage my whole
thing all right
so we're thinking about the brain that
means we're thinking about neurons right
and they're one of my favorite cell
types because they're super specialized
for communicating with one another and
the way that they do that is through a
combination of action potentials which
are electrical signals and through
neurotransmitters which are chemical
signals and so let's take a look at how
they might one of the ways that they can
communicate with one another so this so
on the left here is what we call a
presynaptic cell because it's cell body
has a little extension that extends to
another cell the postsynaptic cell and
they meet at a synapse right and that's
the point of a communication between
them so if we took take a look closer
look at those and that synapse we can
see that this presynaptic cell is using
chemical signals in the form of
neurotransmitters to send information to
that postsynaptic cell right does that
make sense everybody cool all right and
the way that the postsynaptic cell can
respond to that signal that signals
coming from outside of the cell itself
in this case from another cell but is
using specialized proteins that are in
its membrane at the synapse and those
are called receptors right so this is
from thanks khanacademy this is from
like another example but this is a
general principle that happens in your
brain in lots of different contexts
right and it turns out that it's really
important for addiction all right so one
of the receptors that cells use to
respond to certain signals are called
opioid receptors and this is a protein a
kind of protein
that I study everyday in the lab and
receptors like I said allow cells to
respond to signals coming from the
outside and so opioid receptors whistle
a cells to respond to opioids right so
this is a cute little receptor here in
the membrane we have extracellular
intracellular all that good stuff right
you guys know that and then we have an
opioid that comes in and I'm gonna call
this binding to the receptor so the
opioid comes in and interacts and binds
with that receptor right and some
examples of things that interact with
opioid receptors are things that your
body makes or endogenous opioids we call
endogenous things that are produced by
your body right so those are things like
endorphins you've heard of endorphins
right cool so there are also exogenously
and those are things that are introduced
from outside of your body and in good
examples of that are morphine oxycodone
and heroin and a really important
medication called methadone that I'm
going to talk about a little bit later
alright so we have an example of a
receptor we have opioid receptors and we
have opioids that interact with them
right so what is going on that allows
that when that cell is responding to the
opioid signal right alright so now we
have kind of a schematic of a couple of
proteins that are affected by opioids so
we have the receptor here so what
happens when an opioid comes in is that
a chemical signal gets propagated and
that signal can go on to affect the
activity of other proteins in the cell
and I'm not going to go into like what
these are what they do even though
they're really interesting and if you
have specific questions you can ask me
about them later but what I want you to
take away is that the summation of all
these effects on on these proteins for a
lot of neurons is less excitability and
so let's get into a little bit of what
that means right so I told you that
neurons communicate with one another by
pumping neurotransmitter or chance but
there's not two other neurons right and
so they do that because they can send
electrical signals that make the
chemical signals propagate right but if
they're less excitable and they're
sending fewer electrical signals that
means
we'll send less chemical signal right
does this make sense to everybody
right okay cool so opioids reduce the
activity of this presynaptic cell that
means that it sends less chemical
signals to it's blue neighbor here right
that's supposed to happen so so opioids
reduced neuronal activity and they
reduced neurotransmitter release and
this is one of the many things that
opioids can do to self but I'm gonna
zero in on this one particular example
all right so a place where this is
actually really important is in the
parts of your brain that have to do with
a neurotransmitter called dopamine and
in parts of your brain that process
information about rewards right and
gotten rewards are things that are like
good right pleasurable or good and it
turns out that one of the places that
dopamine is involved in helping your
brain process or Wars is a place called
the nucleus accumbens and that's a
little region in the front of your brain
that uses dopamine to process
information about the words and I don't
the name comes from another area in the
midbrain called the VTA the ventral
tegmental area I'm gonna call it VTA and
a lot of cells that produce dopamine
live and live ETA and they send their
axons that project forward into the
nucleus accumbens where they can release
dopamine into the cells that live there
all right so let's take a closer look at
that projection all right and I want you
to remember that I have them cartoon
here and they look like a really close
together but if you think back to that
last slide they're actually kind of far
apart in the brain cool all right so
these dopamine cells are hanging out in
the ventral tegmental area and VTA and
they released dopamine onto cells in the
nucleus accumbens that are responsible
for generating rewards right or helping
your brain interpret words and so the
dopamine is doing its thing and we get
reward right but that's not the whole
picture
those dopamine cells are not alone and
they're in the company of other neurons
called GABA use a different
neurotransmitter GABA cells that use a
different neurotransmitter called gaba
and what those do is make sure that the
dopamine cells are kind of held in check
so that
is only release when it's appropriate
when you've actually encountered a
reward right so they're doing a thing
and they make sure that there's not too
much dopamine here and it turns out that
that process is really important for
lots of different kinds of rewards you
get you hang out with your friends you
get zopim you dance and you listen to
music or you look at a picture of
Michelle Obama and you get some dope all
right you have a positive social
interaction
dopamine and like I said let's remember
that all of these things are crucial to
our survival right and so one of the
interesting things about drugs and how
they exert their effects is that they
actually mimic the action of all these
naturally rewarding things and they can
generate aberrant reward signals in the
brain so don't mimic the action of
natural rewards in the brain and they
take advantage of that dopamine circuit
that I showed you a few slides back so
over time you get like a natural reward
a little bit goes back down to zero or
not zero and then the system is ready to
respond to another reward later right
oops yeah you do the same thing but they
hyper activate those systems and so it's
happening in a way that's kind of
aberrant for the normal biology and what
that leads to is a lot of huge changes
that are actually not supposed to take
place when dopamine is doing its thing
and so that leads me to the next piece
of the puzzle right what's really
interesting to me is that those gaba
cells that control remember control the
activity of the dopamine cells which
participate in generating reward and the
nucleus accumbens those express opioid
receptors and remember opiate receptors
can decrease neuronal excitability right
I can decrease the amount of message and
so what happens in opioids are present
well if those gaba cells are responding
to it that means that they send out less
of their chemical signal gab
that lets this dopamine so can I do it
something so sometimes fire a little bit
too much and then you get too much
dopamine more dopamine than you would
get with a natural reward and that leads
to I forgot I had that like all same
there we go
at least the new for ik feelings that
people get when they take a drop and in
this case it's an opioid but dopamine
surges are also involved in things like
okay and basically anything that's
reinforcing all right so that accounts
for some of why people take drugs and so
if you think about this imaginary lying
on motivation right so the intensity of
the positive feelings that motivate you
to take drugs we're growing and growing
until and I think you know they start to
go away right so if you keep using drugs
they don't feel as good as they did the
first time right so there's another
piece of the puzzle that we need to
think about so your brain is really
smart and like you said it's really
important for survivors least operate
within like that's very specific set of
parameters right that means that needs
to be able to adapt to the signals and
the effects overall is that there's less
dopamine that gets released over time so
let's look at a couple of the ways that
that happens so let's look first at
these cells that are that are expressing
or have all right so they adapt some of
the ways that they can adapt just by
something called desensitization they
can turn off the receptors that are on
their surface they no longer respond to
the open I can also internalize those
receptors maybe pull them away from the
surface so that they're no longer
accessible to the oh by the oh right
they also change the levels of receptors
so they can insert more they can take
and so all of these different changes
can help normalize the activity of that
dopamine circuit
to drugs let's take another look at some
of the cells that respond to job so it
turns out the dopamine cells that
respond to dopamine do that because they
and those can adapt by and one way is by
taking away they're not is they're not
gonna be high response and so all of
those changes kind of sum to get the
kind of peppy phenomenon that we see
when getting drugs that is in the
response that they get those kind of
positive feelings over time start to get
lower and lower and then they come back
that people who are taking drugs will
start to and I use the amount of the
consumer right and I'm kind of not
telling you anything new about what
people are doing but I hope that you've
been able to kind of like link what
people's patterns of behavior like to
what's going on there right so this
change in behavior is an example of
things that are like tolerance emulating
alright and tolerance is increasing the
amounts of drug that's taken to maintain
the effects I may think you think you're
getting out of a clearer picture of why
people might want to do that and then
there's an issue of dependence right
which is a dysfunction in the absence of
that and what I'm kind of showing you in
these past few slides is that drugs
change the way that the brain functions
we need to be presenting the brain with
those drugs right and so this is
changing the ways that it functions then
maybe if those changes persist on the
drug is impaired something might be
wrong then you take the drugs away right
alright so a lot of those changes result
are having more control that's because
it's like if you think about people who
are depressed like it turns out that is
also affected because it's not just also
helps the PFC do its job so I can change
dopamine acts where you start to lose
control over intake and there are lots
of scientists who are studying that
we're looking at the PFC and looking at
how drugs can reduce I and I'd be remiss
if I didn't do a little bit of a PSI
every time so if you think about where
those windows parts of the brain are
occurring there's actually a big
difference in some of the more mature
guys right so we think about those
places like the nucleus of
that's because changing all right so we
have a little bit more to our picture
all right and that's illustrated from
actually a really cool study that was
done way before anybody in this room
and that actually makes me think about a
really sobering statistic and that's
that about what I'm doing
but we spent a lot of time as addiction
science is making and
so
[Applause]
okay okay end of time I can't
what are your motivations
what were your motive these irons what
was your motivations I for your
motivation study that that's to study
this oh man mmm think about it I've been
in neuroscience the thing that I really
liked about it was I've been a
neuroscientist for a long and I was
really cool about and just what was
really cool about addiction is that I
get to study some little things about
answering questions that are really and
I just really like being apart and I
just really like being apart
just like I'm probably physically but
like my caffeine because I get
[Applause]
music actually has that we have an
organic box they come from the brain
because the brain is the seat of me I
think that's a big thank you so I really
loud like I really get a lot of praise
to little abilities
so it really helps the work that the lab
is doing to identify some wheels I think
I kind of mentioned a little bit what
makes some people more vulnerable just
like any protein the information is
found in your genes and it turns out
that their individual differences so one
of the projects that I'm really excited
about getting into change we actually
know that some of those mutations in so
I want to look really closely at exactly
that's how I would imagine that it has
but I can't tell you yes or no so one
thing you have to keep in mind is
certain kinds of odds is that the things
that come along with them they're really
really done right so with smoking
cigarettes I'm not sure about those
statistics and I'm sorry I didn't how
are you taking in those drugs right so
drugs like heroin can be really
dangerous and harmful to health because
if you're injecting them just like a
really popular way of really popular way
out at least in the nineteen eighties
and kind of going now I'm taking that
end right and that means that you have
like HCV like Hep C right and so though
it's gonna be harmful to help out other
ways but if you're smoking something and
you're also taking in that small and you
have other complications that are not
necessarily brought by the drug itself
on the brain we're on the body but by
the smoke and it's hard and all the
chemicals and stuff like also yeah we
have to think about like what's legal
and what's not so access to cigarettes
is really huge right like people can
smoke when they're 18 so some of those
numbers might be bigger because people
have bigger access to more people use
use alcohol so you saw that 260 million
people that are you know it's an illegal
drug trade compared to something that's
really illegal and heavily policed like
heroin so those numbers are a lot
smaller
so you said that in an unhealthy brain
that's addicted to drugs so how does so
what I would say to that is that when
the brain is functioning differently one
actually one really cool thing and
another project that I'm interested in
is how drugs stress and so there are
parts of your brain like and a good
example is and that is important part of
generating your brain's responses your
brains and your body's responses and so
an interesting thing about lots of
different drugs especially opioids is
that in effect a way that those parts of
your brain I thought both elements that
are responsible for coordinating lots of
different parts of your body right it
changes how those functions so it
changes the way that your brain can
control and so yeah it's like some of
those changes I don't know about
dopamine specifically but some of the
changes that are affected and braying my
drugs can affect how your brain
communicates and coordinates the
different parts your body especially few
things like stress just FYI we are we've
already distributed all of our key genes
but we want to make sure everybody s
here I have two questions one is what
exactly in terms of age is it easier to
be addicted and certain ages than others
so like as a teenager would it be easier
to be addicted that as an adult or as a
childhood I mean in terms of like what
someone's lived experiences or do you
mean like
easier to become addicted at certain
time yeah it's easier to become addicted
statistically speaking of like what
pager don't gotcha yeah so if you
remember and I guess I should have left
my computer plugged in I'm gonna answer
both questions but I want to I want to
make sure that I answer both and don't
freak out cause I'm home okay so um so
yeah like I was saying with some of the
like parts of your brain that are
responsible for regulating like how you
can control craving and how you can
control your impulses they're still
developing when you're younger
so exposing a younger brains and drugs
it's definitely really dangerous
exposing any brains in throw it's too
much can be really impossible out of
problems but if that brain is developing
that means that it's a specific
vulnerable period where lots of even
bigger changes can happen so like you
know so me taking a drug is a lot
different than any of you right because
my brain a lot of those pathways are in
place not very much of it is developing
in the same way or to the same extent
that forces so I would say that I don't
know about in terms of being easy but it
definitely makes a big difference
one other thing um in terms of how easy
it is to overdose what age is it is your
brain more sensitive to overdose oh so
this is another thing yeah so it's a
very individual sort of thing right
thank you for these are both really
great questions I got in terms of age I
don't really know but it's kind of a
very individual thing right so like I
said people develop tolerance
independence in different ways
and there may be some like age core
let's do that but what really happens is
that when people say for instance for
opioids do you guys know um oh my god
Philip Seymour Hoffman right all right
we're like Corey Monson right what may
have happened with them and I'm not the
doctor I don't know is that people who
had trouble with opiate addiction in the
past they develop things like tolerance
so they can take more and more and more
and more without overdose
right well let's say that there's a
period where they don't take those drugs
and then later they come back and
they're like I was able to take this
much before I can I should be able to do
that well that tolerance dependent
starts to go away actually pretty
quickly after and so you come back and
you take more and and yeah so I wish I
wish I knew a little bit more about how
age might come in so that but it's a
really good question
all right so opioid drugs specifically
are some of the most powerful
medications we've ever had right like
like I said people have used drugs for a
long time right and morphine and opioids
are something that we've used was a
super super long time right so like
opium and codeine and that's because
they not only are they addictive they're
super powerful pain relievers right and
they're like actually some of the most
effective anyway that we got so like I'm
sure you all are at the age where you're
like getting your wisdom teeth out right
so who said we said there were some
cheap taking out
oh yeah so my doctor gave me a
prescription for hydrocodone
which is an opioid right now I didn't
need it
so if your doctor gives you all that
hydrocodone don't but yeah so medically
that was kind of an aside I'm sorry but
yeah so medically you know opiates are
really useful but because they're so
useful and because they can also they
also have the you know terrible side
effects and dependence and addiction
that means that they're kind of fraught
right like they carry dangerous so the
more that we use them and the more and
when we don't use them properly that
means that we're more vulnerable to
getting people to and and getting people
addicted and so one of the things that
doctors can do and the matter
profession in general can do is to
better educate doctors and like new
medical students and stuff about how to
use opioid medications properly
something we don't do it and another
thing that I think medical professionals
are really poised to do really well is
to put pressure on Congress and put
pressure on drug distributors to not
over push or deregulate how we manage
drugs because they can be really
dangerous let's get something over here
we've been neglecting your edge of the
room here I was wondering if it's
possible for recovering addicts to
become addicted to their treatment
medication and if so such a great
question alright so that is actually a
really huge misconception that we're
really hoping to fight so a lot of a lot
of the push back against method on and
treatments like it like methadone or
suboxone is that people are saying like
okay you're just substituting one drug
for the other right but let's think
about it this way alright if you already
showed you that like people her method
only maintained don't get high off with
that method and the same goes for the
mystery box now let's say that somebody
is suffering from depression because of
chemical changes that are going on in
the brain we know that antidepressants
are gonna help normalize that and a lot
of the brain to heal right they may take
those and depressants for the rest of
their life they might stop taking this
antidepressants right so if you think
about addiction in that same way like
you're helping is that you're giving
someone a medication allows them to
manage their symptoms right and because
of the way that those addiction
medications work people are not addicted
to those medications right yeah I think
that's we're gonna go with and you can
also think about it like this way you're
in dressing like like I said those
changes are in the brain cause
dysfunction in the absence of that drug
that people are addicted to you right
and I told you a little bit about how
methadone is able to work and that it
mimics the effects of natural endorphins
which are not addicted to
they're like things that your body make
that are like they're for normal
function and because of that you are
lost my train of thought
because of that it's like you're
allowing those receptors to function
normally
you're not inducing those highs you're
not getting that aberrant signaling
you're just replacing something that has
been that you've kind of lost right so
think about like diabetes and insulin
you get type 2 diabetes your body
doesn't make insulin anymore you need to
replace that insulin right you change
the way that your endorphins and opioid
receptors work so they're less function
they have less functionality you can
replace that right yeah question here
let's say a baby is born with a heroin
addiction because the mother did heroin
how did they treat that addiction in the
child and also are they more prone in
their lifetime to become addicted again
oh those are really good questions
right yes so those baby there like a
baby that's poor independent right there
are lots of different detoxification
options that people have I'm not a
doctor so I can't really tell you about
about them but like I said there are
medications and their treatments that we
use for people who are addicted to
heroin and other drugs that I think
would be effective actually have two
members of my lab in here who might be
able to help me out what do you think I
do I do know that I believe that they do
do very low dose like methadone or
suboxone yeah you they people can use
that um obviously the like amount is
very very different
um but people can use that for children
and there's actually a lot of really
interesting research on that other
people in a lab are doing to kind of
answer your second question like can an
addiction early in life or dependency
early in life depending on if it's you
know an infant or even a younger person
affect your likelihood of getting yeah
addicted later in life also yeah so
there's actually a lot of research
looking at in mice and a lot of
longitudinal research and like archival
research and people looking at how drug
exposure like during and after pregnancy
like early in life can predispose or can
well kind of jump the gun here but like
can change the likelihood of being
addicted later and so it actually turns
out in like animals like rodents that
that's actually the case so drug
exposure during certain parts of
pregnancy especially when like the brain
is developing that can predispose those
animals to more drug taking behavior
later and we can actually train animals
to take drugs themselves so it's it's
actually really cool and then with
people yeah people who have who have
early life adversity and who are exposed
to drugs earlier in life have a bigger
chance of developing addictions later
specifically actually with cannabis
so yeah let's we have time for about one
or two more questions before we get out
to the networking activities so I have
two questions okay my first question is
that um the treatments that have been
made do they only work on certain drugs
or do they work on all drugs in general
okay that's a really great question
they've all been great questions but
this is a really great little excited
about it yeah so the treatments I have
up here that I had up here suboxone and
methadone they're really effective for
for opioid addiction right and so a big
problem and another thing that the lab
is working on and actually Amy who
helped me out with that last question is
working on a specific a big there's a
big lack for specific addiction
treatments for other kinds of addiction
right so I'm thinking primarily of
things like cocaine which is another
really common addiction that people have
and we don't have any medications that
are specific for that and my colleague
Amy is actually working on figuring out
a medication that can help address that
but I do have to say that you know
especially when people are using like
more than one kind of drug addressing
the problem with one drug like an opioid
can help also help address the problems
with other things like cocaine if you're
like a combination user and opioids are
involved in lots of other addictions so
helping the opioid system
kiyo can probably help other addictions
as well and my second question is um is
there treatment that have been that has
been created that cuts off drug
addiction like really fast or if not are
we starting to come up with one oh man I
wish that we had something like that
addiction is a really chronic disease so
kind of like the example I gave with
with mental illness like depression or
with diabetes it's a chronic disease and
we can kind of heal some of the changes
but there are a lot of changes that we
don't understand well enough to be able
to reverse yet and we're actually not
sure if they're permanent or not and so
it's a it's a continual process and
medication definitely helps and people
can stay drug-free for the rest of their
lives if they keep up with their
treatments but unfortunately we can't
cure it yet question here so you
mentioned before that that if you don't
take if you take treatment if you get
treatment and you don't take drugs for a
while your brain supposed to heal itself
mm-hmm
how how exactly does that work in your
brain like what happens and how did the
opioid receptors react and yeah so when
people take would take drugs like some
examples I'm thinking of our morphine or
like an opioid right or cocaine what
actually happens is that the numbers of
receptors in the brain change like the
number of opioid receptors in the brain
can change but the amount of endorphins
that like supply them with signal
doesn't actually change and so you have
this relative deficiency of endorphins
and that in part leads to that
dependence right and that's one of the
things that methadone and other
medications can address but over time if
you maintain people in methadone that
those like receptor numbers start to go
to go back to normal and some of the
changes in the dopamine system start to
go back to normal as well and I think I
was um I was telling another one of
y'all about stress systems in the brain
so it turns out that drug use can really
affect the way that your brain responds
to stress and we think that that's also
involved in wipey
we'll take drugs right because things
like withdrawal and craving or really
stressful and so we see that there's
like an inability of your body to
properly regulate its responses to
stress and a lot of that is contained
within parts of the brain and we can see
that when people receive adequate
treatment those parts of the brain start
to go back to normal and they can re
regulate their stress over here hi thank
you for your talk it was really
interesting thank you listening so
what's the side effect of methadone I
think it's the medicine that you guys
used to help people with opioid
addiction mhm and
what happens to your brain when you have
an overdose oh cool uh hard you died
from your brain you die from your heart
what exactly yeah so I'm gonna answer
your second question first because it's
a little more straightforward um well
it's it's a little bit within my
knowledge base right and so with an
opioid specifically one of the things
that kills you is respiratory depression
so there are lots of opioid receptors
throughout the brain and I was only
talking about specific populations of
receptors and reward circuits but they
are also in your brainstem in places
that regulate things like your heart
rate and your breathing right and so it
turns out that like when you get to
certain concentrations you know first
it's like the really good ones the the
like perfect concentrations for like
hitting the receptors and your reward
systems but then as you up that it gets
it can start to affect the function of
those parts of your brain like in a
brain stem that are regulating your
respiratory rate and so people stop
breathing and they expect c8 and that's
one of the things that kills people
during overdose and then as far as
side-effects I actually don't know of
that many and I'm gonna go to my
colleagues again do we know about side
effects
[Laughter]
generally with methadone there's not
very many side effects yeah it is
contraindicated for somebody with like
had a liver issues because that's where
it's primarily processed so in people
that have you know comorbidity with
alcoholism and they have cirrhosis would
be a better treatment option but overall
it's it's actually very well received
theirs is their cardiac QTC I don't
think so
they're definitely opioid receptors in
the heart but like I think that though
that it doesn't really have any of those
like cardiovascular effects or anything
like that but yeah this is Kyle Windus
she was a postdoc in my lab who's like
really awesome
and also studying ways to treat other
addictions and yeah so what she said
wonderful thank you guys for all those
amazing questions yeah this is really
great so I'm really glad actually that
Devin got a chance to introduce that a
few of his lab mates are here one of the
opportunities that you will you guys
will have in the next phase of this is
to move around and network with the
scientists so Devin will be around
he'll probably be able to take a few
more questions if you guys have them
guys listen up there's a few more
instructions and in addition to that
these scientists and a few more who are
already waiting outside for you are
going to be around with some questions
that are like some true/false questions
that we've given them and you guys will
have an opportunity to go up to each of
those scientists and discuss with them
what you think is it true is it false
threw up your data point on our graphs
have a chat with them collect a stamp
from them that you have discussed with
them about this question and if you
complete all three of the questions that
are out there you can participate in an
activity where we get to throw some
colored balls into buckets and
simulate performing an action potential
on sort of the human scale so it should
be kind of a fun activity well we hope
that you guys will work in groups you'll
meet some new people you'll find some
others who have interest similar to
yours in addition to those activities
there's two more things
sit down please let me finish talking
all right ah so one of the activities
that you can do is you can experience
what it feels like for your brain to
undergo habituation or that adaptation
type behavior when your brain is
starting to say okay too much too much
too much I need to readjust in some way
to get back to a new level of normal we
have a few fun activities for you to
experience what habituation feels like
in your brain and then we also have an
opportunity for you to share some of
what you learned today because we think
addiction is super important and not
always talked about in the right ways we
want to give you the opportunity to
communicate with your legislators your
policymaking people to share with them
what you've learned today about
addiction if you think that this is
something that we should be thinking
about as something that affects our
communities and our societies and so we
have resources for lots of people that
you can write to some things you can
write about some legislation that's in
progress so it's an opportunity for you
to share what you've learned and
hopefully we can make an impact on how
our broader society thinks about
addiction in the context that we've
learned about today all right to those
sound like good ideas okay so on your
way out make sure you get a little piece
of paper from the people standing by the
doors have fun